excuse me
hi
ah
three little babes in their bassinets
Angelic little triplets or triple
threats they might have fooled the
others but they won't fool me it's time
to get these teething seething free
the third day
[Music]
forget it
is she trying to throw me off the scent
though she bets her little eyes is she a
killer in disguise with a diaper full of
Criminal Intent Greening Patrick is
pernicious with an appetite so vicious
he would bite the hand that feeds him
with a snare but good that rotten tot be
behind this evil block
[Music]
to kill
like a forensic pediatrician I'll
complete this Inquisition I will name
the neonatal from the cradle that crew
fatal I will find a perpetrator who did
murder
[Music]
or
what if none of it is true
has my inspection been to cursory should
I look outside this Nursery
[Music]
well I pick you
yes yes
how you doing
[Music]